the departure from Israel marks the end
of a long battle by Salah hamuri to stay
in the country he has always called home
he's been imprisoned several times once
for his alleged involvement in the
assassination plot of a former Chief
Rabbi for which he got seven years and
was branded a terrorist by Israel as a
member of the popular front for the
liberation of Palestine
his Jerusalem residency was revoked and
as a dual National with French
citizenship that opened the way for his
deportation to France
the effect made it easier for Israel to
get rid of him
we'll send him to France
un experts say the deportation of
protected persons from an occupied
territory could constitute a war crime
and his supporters believe his case
could Now set a precedent for Israel to
deport other activists the case has also
highlighted the controversial practice
of administrative detention which omori
has been held under since March it
allows Israeli authorities to keep
suspects locked up without charge and
without explaining the evidence against
them hamuri's parents who both live in
occupied East Jerusalem say they have
never been told why he's been imprisoned
this time
they just say vague things that he is a
danger for the security of the country
but they don't give us concrete things
rights groups say more than 800
Palestinians are being held in the same
way in Israeli prisons Rob McBride Al
Jazeera West Jerusalem